Mom, I want to talk to you about something.
Mom- . Right now we have exciting things on the table.
A modeling contract most girls would only dream of.
Why won't you listen to me?
You think I wouldn't notice plane tickets- to Australia.
Even when your daughter is plastered on every magazine in New York,
it's like you still, can't see me.
Cora!
Oh my gosh, look at you!
What does you're mom think about you coming to stay?
She thinks it's a great idea
So.  Cora this is Chicka, and this is Tom. How are you going?
C'mon
When's the last time you went swimming? In the ocean?
I missed most of my childhood,
so I could be, where you wanted me.
I fit in to your life,
and now
I'm doing something on my own terms.
Cora, you can't just always run away.
I am not running away.
I am running towards something else
Something on my own terms.
These are really good
Thank you.
Our family makes strong women,
and you're one of them.
Be proud of that.
Open your eyes, and go Cora go
Things happen,  they change.
We can't control them
What you can control, is how they change.